let's check in now on the very latest
covet numbers our state
is seeing yet another record
unfortunately
62 new deaths reported in just the past
24-hour period
we're looking at more than 2 100 new
cases as well
here in southern nevada we are claiming
the majority of those deaths
at 42 and about 1900 cases the most
recent update showing 170 000 people
have recovered from the virus
in the county that is 87.6 of
all reported cases denise well brian all
counties in nevada
except story and white pine remain
flagged for high coveted case rates and
test positivity
now the latest update during the cobit
mitigation and management task force
meeting today we learned that
the group examined several issues from
compliance
to vaccination efforts to monitoring
personal protective equipment
nevada is good at least for now but the
nevada hospital association reports a
possible shortage of things like
large gloves extra large gowns and
syringe needles pretty soon
so we're closely monitoring that as we
go on
we have not seen that yet here in nevada
but other states are starting to see
that
same with oxygen we continue to monitor
the oxygen status of all of our
hospitals
northern nevada hospitalizations are
going down but they're not here in
southern nevada
a recent report says 10 out of the 14
facilities have a capacity of 90 percent
or higher when it comes to virus
patients the numbers may continue to go
up until mid-february
because of holiday transmission